daily wire says the everything store
appears to have a double standard when
it comes to gender identity content
amazon recently rejected the daily wires
paid ads for matt walsh's book what is a
woman saying the ads contain prohibited
content
the company cited a policy banning
content that questions a person's sexual
orientation
an amazon advisor support uh wrote in an
email to daily wire we don't allow
content that appears to infer or claim
uh to diagnose treat reverse or question
sexual orientation
it's a strange rationale the article
continues what is woman is not about
sexual orientation as much as gender
identity and the radical progressive
ideology around it yeah i mean this just
makes
this of course makes no sense at all
actually
um yeah the book doesn't deal with
sexual orientation at all that's that is
not the subject of the book
and as far as sexual orientation goes
you know as as the the transgender
agenda gender ideology runs roughshod
over um
over
what was in the past the leftist agenda
especially as it pertains to feminists
like we've talked about this week it
also does this with um you know with
so-called gay rights because like sexual
orientation
doesn't even really mean anything
anymore if your gender doesn't mean
anything
and also
if it is as we've been told you know
your sexual orientation is immutable it
cannot be changed
this is one of the this has always been
or at least when i say always for the
last you know
a couple of decades anyway on the left
this has been
one of the number one most sacrosanct
creeds that your your sexual orientation
is set in stone you're born with it and
it can never change well um if that's
the case then you can also it it's also
impossible to change your gender
because if you can change your gender
that means you can change your sexual
orientation
you know if you're a gay man attracted
to men because that means you're a gay
man and then you become a woman and
you're still attracted to men well that
means your sexual orientation has
changed so that's just yet another
inherent contradiction created by gender
ideology um but
so so
what is amazon doing here um
they they realize
they can't
justify
banning the book because
that's what they would like to do they'd
like to ban the book outright and say
you can't sell this book on our site but
uh they do have their own guidelines
which they've published everybody can
read and they realize that according to
those guidelines the book doesn't
violate any of them
now of course it doesn't make sense
that
you know if that the book is so hateful
that and violates policies and so
you can ban advertising but you also but
you still but by according to your own
guidelines you can't just ban the book
out right like if it
if it if it violates the standards for
advertising then you think it also
violates the standards for being sold on
the site at all so that doesn't make a
lot of sense
but um i think this is just kind of
the compromise amazon has come up with
especially to appease their own woke
employees who uh infamously have been
you know literally crying about the
books that i've published on their site
amazon realizes that
they can suppress and censor the book in
certain ways
without drawing a lot of backlash and
negative publicity so they're going as
far as they can
without making it into a story
and they realize that censoring the ads
for whatever reason
isn't the story banning the book
outright is a story and so uh that's
that's what they're doing that's that's
the compromise they've come up with well
if you enjoyed that video be sure to hit
the subscribe button and ring the bell
to get more content like it if you're
craving more content go watch or listen
to my full show at dailywire.com spotify
or wherever you get your podcast
you